des militaires qui bloquent les routes
l'icône en dessous qui arrêtait l'état
d'urgence proclamé un coup d'état vient
d'avoir lieu en birmanie et le pays
risque de replonger dans la dictature
mais comment en est on arrivé là et
pourquoi l'armée at elle décidé de
reprendre le pouvoir
[Musique]
la birmanie où le myanmar selon son nom
officiel
c'est ce pays d'asie du sud est et pour
tout comprendre à cette situation il
faut revenir un peu en arrière devenu
indépendant en 1947 il va sombrer dans
la dictature en 1962 à cause d'un coup
d'état
en 1988 un mouvement de contestation
apparaît aimé au pouvoir de nouveaux
généraux il organise des élections qui
seront remportées par la ligue nationale
pour la démocratie le parti d'aung san
suu kyi
sauf que la junte militaire ne veut pas
céder le pouvoir les élections sont à
leur annulés et auxonne sotchi et
d'assigner à résidence par la suite
l'armée essaie de développer
économiquement le pays qui prend du
retard par rapport à d'autres de la
région comme la thaïlande ou l'indonésie
et pour le faire elle est obligés
d'entamer une transition démocratique
l'armée a ouvert à la fin des années 90
début des années 2000 a ouvert le
processus politique
tout simplement parce que les généraux
birmans ont constaté que le retard
accumulé pour développer le pays
devenait vraiment pénalisant pour
l'avenir pour débloquer ce processus il
fallait intéresser les pays occidentaux
et ils ont donc décidé de libéraliser à
la fois l'économie et les jeux
politiques mais cette ouverture n'est
qu'une façade puisque l'armée veut
toujours garder le pouvoir
exemple en 2008 quand la junte change la
constitution birmane
elle va mettre en place des garde-fous
pour ne pas perdre de son influence
d'une part le fait qu'ils se gardent
trois ministères régaliens important les
frontières l'armée évidemment et la
sécurité intérieure deuxième point il
s'octroyait également 25% des sièges
à l'assemblée nationale tout en
définissant bien les règles du jeu pour
modifier une loi constitutionnelle il
fallait 75 % d'approbation
donc grosso modo il se donnait un droit
de veto sur les amendements
constitutionnels en dessous çi sera
libéré en 2010 après avoir passé 15 des
21 dernières années en résidence
surveillée
en 2011 elle devient députée et le
processus démocratique en birmanie
semble s'accélérer en 2015 les premières
élections libres ont lieu elles sont
remporté largement par le camp dansante
sotchi avec 70 3% des fois elle devient
alors conseillère spéciale de l'état ce
qui lui permet de facto de diriger le
pays
sauf sur les questions régaliennes pour
lesquels la junte militaire garde le
pouvoir grâce à la constitution de 2008
une situation qui fragilisera aung san
suu kyi lors de la crise des rohingya de
2017 lorsque plus de 700 mille personnes
appartenant à cette ethnie musulmane
quittent leur pays pour fuir les
exactions de l'armée birmane
évidemment le pouvoir central a peu de
marge de manoeuvre puisque armée
frontières et stabilité intérieure
relève de la tatmadaw c'est à dire des
forces armée birmane ou ayant des choses
elle aurait dû parler plus sur ces
questions là mais d'une manière générale
elle n'a jamais caché le fait que son
but ultime c'était de remettre en cause
ce cadre autoritaire fixées par la junte
à ce moment là les militaires mettez
place et a sauté devant devant une
espèce de dilemme où elle prenait
position pour les musulmans et auquel
cas elle été décrédibilisés au lieu de
l'armée et aux yeux d'une partie de la
population ultra nationaliste où elle se
taisait et l essayer de trouver une
solution aux coulisses elle essaye de
peser mais le rapport de force n'est pas
en sa faveur en 2020 deux événements
majeurs vont pousser l'armée à vouloir
reprendre le pouvoir
le premier se déroule au mois de mars
lorsque le parti johnson tucci déposent
des amendements pour changer la
constitution les militaires l'ont très
mal pris les amendements n'ont pas ne
sont pas passés en août 2020 mais
néanmoins ils ont vraiment senti le vent
du boulet
le deuxième événement majeur ce sont les
élections législatives 8 novembre et
c'est un raz-de-marée en faveur dans le
sens où tu chies face pour militer son
parti obtient 81 2% des voix sauf que là
encore la junte sans la situation lui
échapper et ne veut pas perdre pouvoir
ils vont faire état de fraudes qui ont
eu lieu lors de l'élection pour
justifier son d'annulation du scrutin
imparfait mais néanmoins ils disent tous
ces observateurs que dans l'ensemble
néanmoins ce scrutin reflète en moyenne
la réalité politique du pays à savoir
que la grande majorité des birmans
continue de soutenir la ligue de
saint-paul démocratie et veulent
soutenir la transition vers plus de
démocratie et donc mettre en cause le
couloir de l'armée depuis le 1er février
mini terre organisent un coup d'état et
fonde arrêté en dessous petit pourquoi
c'est mieux maintenant
et bien parce que ce lundi 1er février
c'était le jour où le parlement devait
se réunir sa première session depuis ces
nouvelles élections
c'était le jour j où on allait entériner
si vous voulez officiellement la
nouvelle victoire du parti dom-tom sushi
pourquoi aujourd'hui la remise mais lola
c'est que elle craint que comme sushi
forte de sa nouvelle victoire va vouloir
pousser pour une réforme
constitutionnelle et remettre en cause
ces garanties qui permettent à l'armée
et tout son réseau économique militaire
de garder une forte influence sur le
pays
c'est cette volonté de garder le pouvoir
qui plombent aujourd'hui la birmanie
dans l'incertitude dans une situation
qui ressemble beaucoup à celle que le
pays a connues en 1990 quand l'élection
danza dessous de fille avait été annulé
aujourd'hui le pays semble avoir fait un
bond en arrière de 30 ans
[Musique]